>> Tucker: THAT’S FOR SURE.
IT’S A MESS BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
OUT OF CASH AND PEOPLE ARE OUT
OF CASH BECAUSE THEY DON’T HAVE
JOBS.
MORE THAN 3 MILLION AMERICANS
FILED FOR UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
THE LAST WEEK OF MARCH WHICH
MARK THINK QUADRUPLED THE
PREVIOUS RECORD IN THE COUNTRY.
IN A MATTER OF MONTHS, JOBLESS
FIGURES LIKE THAT COULD LOOK
SMALL BY COMPARISON.
GOLDMAN SACHS ESTIMATES LATER
THIS YEAR AND AMERICA’S
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE COULD HIT 15%
WHICH COULD BE THE HIGHEST
FIGURE SINCE THE 1930s AND
THAT’S ALMOST 25 MILLION PEOPLE
AT WORK.
GOLDMAN’S ESTIMATE ISN’T EVEN
THE HIGHEST ONE.
ACCORDING TO THE ST. LOUIS
BRANCH OF THE FEDERAL RESERVE
BANK LOAN EMPLOYMENT COULD PEEK
AS HIGH AS 32% WHICH IS
37 MILLION PEOPLE OUT OF WORK.
IN CASE YOU WERE WONDERING,
THAT’S WORSE THAN THE WORST YEAR
OF THE GREAT DEPRESSION.
AT SOME POINT CORONAVIRUS WILL
BE GONE BUT WE COULD LIVE WITH
THE CRUSHING UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS FOR FAR LONGER AND
THAT’S A DISASTER FOR PEOPLE,
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES BUT
IT’S ALSO A THREAT TO THE
STABILITY OF OUR COUNTRY.
NOTHING BEATS A NATION MORE
VOLATILE THAN THE HUGE NUMBERS
OF PEOPLE WHO DON’T HAVE JOBS
AND THAT’S ALWAYS TRUE.
SO WE NEED TO DO WHATEVER WE CAN
TO PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING.
HERE’S THE AMAZING THING.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS DOING
ITS BEST TONIGHT TO MAKE IT MUCH
WORSE.
TODAY ON APRIL 1ST THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
RELEASED 20,000 NEW H2B VISAS
FOR SEASONAL WORKERS TO COME
INTO AMERICA AND TAKE JOBS LIKE
LANDSCAPING, FOOD PROCESSING AND
RESORTS.
ANOTHER 15,000 VISAS WILL BECOME
AVAILABLE NEXT MONTH IN MAY.
THESE ARE BONUS VISAS BY THE
WAY.
BY LAW, THE UNITED STATES ONLY
HAS TO OFFER 66,000 VISAS PER
YEAR BUT HOMELAND SECURITY
SECRETARY CHAD WOLF HAS USED HIS
DISCRETIONARY POWERS TO ADD
35,000 EXTRA VISAS.
SO THAT’S A TOTAL OF 100,000
WORKERS COMING TO THIS COUNTRY
TO TAKE JOBS DURING THE SINGLE
BIGGEST UNEMPLOYMENT CRISIS IN A
CENTURY.
IT’S DEMENTED.
YET IT GETS WORSE THAN THAT.
YESTERDAY DHS NOTIFIED 85,000
NEW WINNERS OF THE H1B VISA
LOTTERY AND THEY CAN BEGIN
FILLING OUT APPLICATIONS FOR
JOBS IN THE OCTOBER.
THAT IS JUST WHEN UNEMPLOYMENT
COULD BE REACHING ITS PEAK AND
WHEN CORONAVIRUS COULD COME BACK
AS THE WEATHER COOLS.
IT ALLOWS THEM TO HIRE
FOREIGNERS AND IT’S A FRAUD OF
COURSE, WELL-DOCUMENTED FRAUD.
IN PRACTICE THE VISAS ARE USED
TO IMPORT TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
TECH VISAS FROM INDIA SO THE
SILICON VALLEY CAN PROFIT FROM A
CHEAPER WORKFORCE.
THE BIG WINNERS IN THIS SCHEME
ARE COMPANIES LIKE APPLE, GOOGLE
AND IBM WHICH TAKE IN OF H1B
WORKERS EVERY YEAR.
AMERICAN WORKERS ARE ORDERED TO
TRAIN THEIR FOREIGN REPLACEMENTS
AND FIRED ONCE THEY ARE NO
LONGER USEFUL.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR A
LONG TIME AND IT’S ALWAYS BEEN
DISGUSTING BUT NOW IT’S A THREAT
TO OUR COUNTRY AND THAT’S NOT AN
OVERSTATEMENT.
IN A YEAR WERE TENS OF MILLIONS
OF AMERICANS COULD BE LOOKING
FOR WORK OUR GOVERNMENT IS
IMPORTING MORE THAN 150,000
WORKERS FROM ABROAD.
THAT’S WITHOUT COUNTING
THOUSANDS OF H TO A AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS WHO WILL BE COMING
AS WELL.
THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO STOP THIS
FROM HAPPENING AND HE CAN.
IF PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS ABLE TO
IGNORE EXISTING LIMIT
IMMIGRATION LAW AND CREATE
DHAKA, WHICH HE DID, IT’S
POSSIBLE FOR OUR PRESIDENT TO
PROTECT THE NATION.
IN AMERICAN LAW GIVES HIM
EXPLICITLY THAT’S RIGHT.
THIS IS FROM SECTION 1182F TITLE
VIII IN THE U.S. CODE.
"ONE OF THE PRESIDENT FINDS THAT
THE ENTRY OF ANY ALIENS OR ANY
CLASS OF ALIENS IN THE
UNITED STATES WOULD BE
DETRIMENTAL TO THE INTEREST IN
THE UNITED STATES HE MAY MAKE A
PROCLAMATION TO SUSPEND THE
ENTRY OF ALL ALIENS OR CLASS OF
ALIENS AS IMMIGRANTS WERE
NONIMMIGRANTS OR IMPOSE ON THE
ENTRY OF ALIENS ANY RESTRICTIONS
HE MAY DEEM APPROPRIATE."
IT’S VERY CLEAR.
THE SUPREME COURT JUST AFFIRMED
THIS LAW AND SO IT’S REAL.
THAT WAS LEVIED TO PROTECT
AMERICANS FROM TERRORISM BUT NOW
WE ARE FACING AN IMMEASURABLY
GREATER PRICELESS THAN DUMB
ACADEMIC CRISIS THAN TERRORISM.
HE COULD FRACTURE OUR SOCIETY,
ERODE OUR RIGHTS, SHATTER OUR
INSTITUTIONS, IT COULD TRANSFORM
THIS COUNTRY INTO A POOR
COUNTRY.
THAT COULD HAPPEN.
PREVENTING THAT FROM HAPPENING
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT TEST THIS
PRESIDENT OR ANY PRESIDENT IN
OUR LIFETIME WILL FACE.
THE TIME TO PLACATE CORPORATE